joining me now is Pastor Cory Brooks CEO
of project Hood Pastor Brooks how
utterly demoralizing um it must be for
these residents what's going on um is he
a reflection of the way others are
feeling well he seems to be a reflection
of what others are feeling you know
Chicago is a microcosm of what's going
on all across the country U we've been
made a sanctuary uh City and uh you know
typically uh the citizens would have
something to say about that but here in
Chicago we're not getting we're not able
to practice a true democracy by saying
if we want to be a sanctuary City or not
and as a consequence um they're being
flooded into our neighborhoods um and
and lots of funds are being invested uh
into individuals who are not American
citizens and for a lot of people uh that
seems to be a major problem yeah
speaking of that here's another Chicago
woman who spoke out at the city council
meeting
watch I'm not for the sanctuary City and
the reason reason why I'm not for the
sanctuary city is because people have
waited years to come in here legally not
just transported on these buses dropped
off in our neighborhoods raay of crime
almost got hit several times just making
it down here today and this is
ludicrous wow Pastor Brooks that really
resonates with me my mother is um an
immigrant a legal immigrant to this
country not only did she go through the
proper process but back when she became
a a a legal citizen the FBI went and
talked to her family back in her home
country I mean that's how much security
um we had back then compared to now
where they're being vetted within a
24-hour period I know that for myself
because I went down to the border and
spoke to people who are doing some of
the vetting and then they get on an
airplane and they come to your city and
where's the compassion for your the
residents in
Chicago yeah you know most black people
have no problem with legal immigration
we're welcoming to our communities we're
welcoming to our neighborhoods the
problem that we're experiencing is the
illegal immigration that's going on the
fact that we're a sanctuary City uh
individuals are taking it upon
themselves to fly uh to Chicago or be
busted to Chicago and as a result of
that a lot of funds that typically
hopefully would have went to our schools
that are deplorable um fighting crime in
our neighborhood that and and in Chicago
that desperately needs it um those funds
would have gone toward those issues but
as a result those funds are being spent
on immigrants illegal immigration uh and
that just should not be in any city in
America so that man said Trump come here
and clean it up do you feel I I just
need a direct question you're you're in
touch with a lot of black uh people in
that Community are other people saying
other black African-Americans are they
saying Trump come here and clean it up
do they want Trump over Biden are they
blaming are they giving the right uh
people the the respon responsibility for
what's happened at our border and what's
now happening to your city there's no
doubt about it that people are blaming
uh Biden and there's no doubt about it
that there should be an uptick uh the
poll suggests uh for Trump especially
young amongst uh black males um a lot of
us feel like uh for far too long a lot
of uh people in our community have been
so loyal to the Democratic party that
and it has not paid off and it is not
paying off and as you know a lot of
individuals believe that they should now
consider taking their vote elsewhere and
I believe you're going to see a real
uptick uh in the voting of black males
for Donald Trump in the upcoming
collection very interesting Pastor Corey
Brooks you do a lot of good work in
Chicago we appreciate you coming in hey
Sean Hann here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else